how good or bad are your feet well Rocky
stopped by the Good Feet store the
sponsors of this segment to learn how
they can help you assess that and
relieve foot knee and back pain
[Music]
welcome to the Good Feet store where
America's arch support experts help
people relieve foot back and knee pain
we've created a three-step system
that'll help improve your quality of
life and no matter what kind of life you
walk you need Good Feet I would say 95
of people benefit from our Orthotics
from your young soccer player all the
way to your retired person who wants to
live their golden life this is what
makes the Good Feet store unique our
patented three-step system is what
separates us from the industry good feed
Orthotics support the four arches so so
many people don't even know that we have
four arches once you support the four
arches that's what creates the change
helps align your body and helps you be
better balanced so what we do we offer a
free fitting and it's customized to your
arch type and your needs because we do
carry over 30 different styles with
different flexibilities to fit your
lifestyle so when you come in for a free
fitting all you got to do is bring in
some of your normal Footwear choices the
free fitting will start with an ink
footprint to see the relationship of
your feet with the ground then we'll
take a measurement we'll go ahead and
customize your three-step system and
we'll come out have you try it out and
walk and see how you feel it's about
feeling and learning what good feet are
so you see it here evenly distributed
weight toes line up nice and neat and
you see a well-defined arch fulfilling
the client's needs and the team's heart
my name is Sarah I work at the good Feed
Store I've been here for over a year it
definitely brings me a lot of Joy just
being able to like I said help people
just sing the tears and not even just in
the person that's coming through the
door less than pain but their spouse or
their family members as well like them
seeing the difference in their family
member as well and with every good foot
comes a great Story the success stories
that I have seen just in the store
physically people
leaving their walkers behind or just
being able to bring in that confidence
into their walk when they're just doing
the test walk in store and then with the
follow-ups just people saying I'm able
to walk without pain there's a lady that
I didn't originally help her but she's
came into the store and I helped her do
one of her swap outs but in that
conversation we we made a bond and now
she's brought back other people to us
because she's had so much success with
the Orthotics herself so she's brought
in three other friends that are also
having their own success as well another
one is Michael borham he stopped by
after seeing a commercial hoping the
Good Feet store could help him with his
knee pain because I do a lot of walking
and I like to dance
yeah I need my niece I would recommend
my friends or family to check them out
it's worth it
thank you to the good feed store for
sponsoring this segment you can find
them in Henderson just call
702-331-7787 or visit goodfeet.com for
more information they have a special
offer for you receive free Comfort
cushions with a purchase of their
three-step system we'll be right back